The study that showed the critical importance of attachment bonding in social
stimulation and development is the Tiffany Field's 1979 study. She studied
newborns who were whisked away from their mothers right after they were born.
Either cause they were born prematurely or they were too small or they were at
risk of not surviving. She got permission from a hospital to do an experiment
where she has two groups. So, half the babies that were preterm or at risk
received the standard care. And that treatment was removal from mom, and
isolated in a germ-free incubator. The other half of the preterm at risk babies
received the new treatment. This was 15 minutes of skin to skin touching and
stroking from the nurse, every single day.